Today we’re back with another round of your
questions!
We’ve got questions about microbes, questions
about how James, our Master of Microscopes
takes care of microbes, and questions about
how we make these videos.
Some of these things we’ve seen come up
frequently in comments, and others are questions
sent in via Twitter, Patreon, and Instagram.
So thank you to everyone who’s been commenting
and asking questions, we couldn’t do any
of this without your shared excitement for
all things microcosmos.
And every one of your comments and questions
steers this channel on our journey.
Question number one, we’ve been asked if
there are any species of fungi that live in
the aqueous environment?
And yes, there are!
We featured some in our recent episode about
nematode-trapping fungi, which are very fascinating
and also a teensy bit creepy.
There are also other fungal parasites.
These amoeba are infected with Amoebophilus
simplex, a fungus that attacks certain amoeba
and then grow spores out of them.
These euglenids are also infected with some
kind of fungus though we couldn’t tell you
which kind.
Moving out of the water onto the land, we’ve
got a question about whether we’ve had the
chance to observe motile soil microbes, and
whether we’ve been able to look at species
that come from more than 1 mile down in the
ground.
We’ve talked a bit about soil microbes,
but the fact is that the soil has an incredible
diversity of life in it, and we’ve barely
scratched the surface (literally).
And we’d love to dig deeper so that we can
see some of the organisms that live a mile
or more underground.
But we cannot do that ourselves, so James
has been trying to get ahold of some samples
from drilling companies.
So fingers crossed on that.
Next question: Do organisms like Gastrotrich
have gut flora?
Well they almost certainly do have gut flora.
Bacteria are basically everywhere, including
in the guts of microscopic animals.
As for their role in gastrotrichs?
It could be anything.
Our own microbiome is made up of bacteria
that do everything from help us digest food
to manage our immune system, and nature is
full of many incredible examples of how gut
flora and other forms of microbiome inform
the lives of animals.
So there’s probably something cool going
on there.
But no scientist, as far as we know, have
yet investigated it.
One of the most common questions we get is
how to start your own journey to the microcosmos.
The easiest thing is to get some water from
outside and look at it under a microscope,
but of course, picking and purchasing a microscope
can be overwhelming.
Like any hobby, it’s probably best to start
off simple and see what works for you, get
some experience, and then build from there.
Also, we might be working on some things to
help you narrow down your search in the future,
but we can’t talk about it yet.
Of course, microscopes are only one part of
the microcosmos experience—the other big
thing are the microbes that you’re gonna
look at with them.
And we’ve gotten a few questions about how
to best take care of our invisible friends
for the long term.
The key is to try to get samples that are
on the larger size.
Having a larger sample will make any environmental
changes happen slower.
It’s like the difference between leaving
a bottle of water out in the sun versus a
whole pool of water: the bottle will get warmer
faster.
Now, obviously you’re not gonna be gathering
a whole pool’s worth of microbes, but in
general, it’s best to err on the side of
larger samples so that you can provide your
microbes with a steady environment.
In addition, you’ll also want to try and
mimic as much of their original environment
as possible.
So collect leaves, sediment, and aquatic plants
from wherever you’re sampling to make your
microbes feel at home.
We also get a ton of questions about how to
identify microbes.
We’ve made an episode about just this very
thing, but the crux of that whole discussion
is that…it’s really a thing built on a
lot of internet sleuthing and practice.
But with that said, our very own James Weiss
will be publishing a book next year called
The Hidden Beauty of the Microscopic World,
to be published by Penguin Random House, which
will be a picture heavy book that might help
you with your identification needs.
Which is very exciting!
Congratulations James!
Moving on to a microscope question: what is
the minimum magnification needed to see single-celled
organisms?
Well, there are actually some single-celled
organisms large enough to be seen without
a microscope, especially if you put them in
front of a strong light like this stentor
culture.
When it comes to using a microscope, we’ve
been able to use a magnification as low as
40x to see our samples.
Now it’s time to get into some behind the
scenes stuff.
Several of you have been asking about whether
there are any microbes that we want to show
but cannot for some reason.
And yes, definitely.
There are so many incredible microbes out
there, and while we’re fortunate that our
accessible sources have so many unique things
for us to find, there’s still plenty more
that we want to see and that we want to show
you.
Right now, we’re hoping to find a super
rare ciliate called thysonomorpha, which has
weird retractable tentacles.
And then there’s plenty on our wishlist,
a bit more of a reach.
We’d love to feature archaea, which are
single-celled prokaryotes distinct from bacteria.
But archaea are super tiny, even by microcosmos
standards, so they’re hard for us to find
right now.
We’re planning to get fluorescent illumination
in the future, which will let us stain for
archaeans so we can see them better.
Archaeans are famed for their ability to survive
in some of the hottest and saltiest places
on the planet, making them what we call extremophiles.
And we really, really want to be able to talk
more about extremophiles because it’s incredible
to learn more about how microbes are able
to survive in some of the harshest environments.
Unfortunately, we don’t know how to do that
yet.
We don’t know how to take care of them or
capture them on video, and that is on our
wishlist.
We also got a question wanting to know whether
James has discovered something that’s not
just new to him, but new to science.
And it turns out he has!
He found this ciliate a few months ago and
couldn’t identify it, so he contacted some
scientists working on this group of organisms.
There are reports of similar species from
the 1930s, but so far no description matches
what he’s found.
So James is working on trying to culture them
and maybe do some genomic analysis, and hopefully
he’ll get to write a paper and name the
organism.
If he gets to do that, we might even ask you
all to pitch in some ideas!
Someone else asked whether we worry about
getting sick from some of the things we’re
working with, which is always a good question
to ask because safety is an important thing
to keep track of when you’ve got hundreds
of containers full of microbes in your home.
So James exercises caution by not handling
the containers with an open wound.
He also washes his hands after working with
the microscope.
The real challenge is making sure his cats
are staying safe because cats, you know, they’re
cats.
So he’s trained them to avoid his samples
by blowing puffs of air on their face when
they try to climb up on his table and his
window sills.
These are the little bits of insight you get
when you watch the questions videos.
On to some more nitty gritty: after we’re
done observing the organism on the slide,
what do we do with them?
Do we dispose of them or culture them?
We don’t really try to culture everything
but instead, we try to create little copies
of the environment that the organisms came
from.
So when we’re done checking a slide, everything
either gets washed back into the sample container
or into a pond aquarium.
But if we do want to culture them, James uses
a micropipette to select the cells one by
one and transfer them onto a clean water drop.
He’ll repeat this a few times to wash the
cells, and then put them into some water to
culture.
We get a lot of wonderful comments from you
all about the music on this channel and you’ve
also asked about how it’s composed.
The music is made by the very talented Andrew
Huang, who you can find on YouTube.
Link in the description, and he said the following:
“The music for Microcosmos is some of the
most organic composing I’ve ever done, where
I generally just set out to explore a mood
as suggested by the team or based on my own
viewing of the series.”
I think he did a really wonderful job.
This question’s from Andrew Taylor who asked
on YouTube: “What motivated you to create
this channel?
Why did you branch out into the more relaxing
narrative instead of continuing the high energy
of your other productions?
And hey, this is actually a question for me,
neat!
Well, at first I was motivated to make the
channel after seeing some of James’ videos
on YouTube and I reached out and I was like,
“We should talk about these things.”
But it terms of the vibe, like when you’re
making something, what it’s gonna feel like,
how it’s going to be experienced, that can’t
just come down to like what you know how to
do or what you’re good at, or what’s become
expected of you, or even a particular platform
like YouTube.
It has to be about what is right for the content.
And when I first saw James’ videos, there
was a vibe already there, and so we just sorta
followed that vibe.
It was also a moment when I, personally, needed
some opportunities maybe to slow down a little
bit sometimes.
That has only felt more necessary to me in
the years since we launched.
So, I was excited to make something a little
more chill.
And finally, from time to time we receive
comments asking us about money.
Maybe asking about our Patreon, our sponsorships,
or YouTube ad revenue, but the questions mostly
boil down to a curiosity about how the finances
of a YouTube channel work, and I love talking
about that stuff.
Journey to the Microcosmos is produced by
a larger company, Complexly, that makes SciShow
and Crash Course and Eons, and about a dozen
other YouTube channels.
And when we launch something new, at that
company, we invest money that we made from
other things to try something in the hopes
that the new thing will become self-sustaining.
It will gain an audience.
It will gain support.
And it will be able to continue to exist.
When those things aren’t able to sustain
their costs, that’s when a show gets cancelled.
We can’t make shows that cost more money
to produce than they make.
So what do we spend money on?
Several things.
Our writer, Deboki, on Matt’s editing and
graphics and production, on Andrew’s music,
and, of course, helping James continue his
amazing work.
The one thing about this that is free is the
narration, which I guess I throw in for free
cuz I’m the CEO of Complexly and I just
really like to work on this show.
The good news is, that because this channel
has the support of our Patreon patrons and
advertisers, it’s now making enough money
that we can think not just about how to survive,
but also about how to keep making our content
better.
Now, a lot of these things are expensive,
but particularly with microscopy, the smallest
microscope parts can cost thousands of dollars,
but thanks to your support, we’ve been able
to upgrade to a 4K camera to produce even
better looking footage, and recently, James
able to get a brand new microscope so that
we can share the amazingness that is DIC microscopy.
Our next goal is to hit $5,000 a month on
Patreon, and that’s gonna let us buy a 40x
objective for the new microscope similar to
the one we’ve used in our past brightfield
and dark field clips.
That way we can still get the stunning footage
we get with DIC microscopy, but also get a
more zoomed out view of the microcosmos.
So, if you’re interested in joining our
amazing group of patrons, you can head over
to patreon.com/journeytomicro, and together,
we can change our perspective on the world.
And if you can’t join our patreon, all of
your support in views, comments, likes, and
questions helps us figure out where to take
our journey next.
So thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And again thank you to our Patreon patrons,
all of these people here, who yes, as I have
just said, are the reason that this show can
continue to exist.
So, if you are thankful for this show, these
are the people you need to thank.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.